もう一つお釈迦様がよくよく考えているんですね
ヴィバーヴァタンニャー
ヴィバーっていうのは
バーハは存在の反対 非存在なんですね
いわゆる存在したくないよという欲は
それは虚無主義と似てるんですね
存在は嫌だと思うのはいいんだけど
だから存在嫌いだ 嫌いだ思うと
それでもう怒りみたいな欲なんですね
虚無主義なんですね そのつもある限りは悟りではないと
この修行する仙人たちがすごくババタンニャーあるんですね
それは悪いと思わないんですね
ただ永遠になっていたいという気持ちだからね
本人がそれ悪いと思わないんですね
そこで釈尊がこれからまた瞑想を続けて
この心もやっぱり生滅変化しているんではないかと
波だからね 波っていうのは生滅生滅生滅だからね
だから原因があって生じるんですね
原因があって滅するんですね
同じ原因が揃っているならばいいんだけど
原因が変わっちゃうでしょうね
ですから ここはここも最終解脱ではありませんと
と決めるんですね ここまで進んでも
もう生まれ変わったらもう無色界の梵天になるんです
もう物質とは関係ない
物質は捨てちゃったんだから
これはもう物質ではなく
ただ心だけの世界 ですから
生まれ変わったら心だけですから
誰にでもその人とコンタクトできません
この世界に行ったら もう他の輪廻転生している人々とはまるっきりコンタクトなし
で いわゆる宇宙空間は取らないんです
宇宙空間まったく取らないんだから
どこにいるかとはないんですよ
この無色界の梵天どこにあるかと
言えないんです 宇宙空間は取りませんから
物質は取りませんから
そこまでは他の宗教で言ってるかどうかはね
まあ言ってるのはどうかな
ちょっとまあ僕は勉強していないんだからね
そこまできめ細かくはね
分かりませんですけど
一応私はあのもう浅い
まあちょっとちょっと目に触れただけの知識で言えば
やっぱり真我ですか 我ですか
霊魂 魂とか そういう何かの永遠たる実体と一体になるというレベルでしか説明できてないようには感じがするんですね
その無色界はそれとは随分違う世界なんです
もっとすごいレベルが高いんです
でも遠い昔はこの物質と関係ないんだと
この霊魂の働きは という風な概念もあったんです
ですから このブラフマンのニルグナ・ブラフマンという
このヒンドゥー教のことを知っている方々は知っていると思いますけど
ニルグナ・ブラフマンという言葉があるんです
このアドバイタ・ヴェーダーンタとかね
シャンカラサンとかね
そういう哲学的な宗教哲学では
ヒンドゥーのこのニルグナ・ブラフマンという言葉が出てくるので
この あの これサットグナ・ブラフマンに置きたい
ニルグナっていうのは何にも特色ないという意味で
ブラフマンというのはアートマン
魂ですね いわゆる超越している魂ですね
我々の個我ではないんです
真我なんです その真我にはニルグナ
何の特色もないんだと
というふうに それは哲学者が言ってるんだからただの言葉なんですけど
その言葉が出てきたのは遠い昔
そういう真我を体験した人がいなかったならば
哲学者に遊ぶ言葉が出てこないんですね
ですから まあもしかするとお釈迦様の時代も
あるいはもうほんのちょっと後でも
この瞑想をしてヨーガをやって
究極的にヨーガをやって
自分の瞑想体験には何の特色もない
例えば空無辺とか色無辺とか
前言ったこのアーキンチャンに当てはめると日本語で何でしたっけ？無生無常
無生無常とかね ナッシングネスとか何とか
例えばナッシングネスということを体験したならば
自分が無辺的な存在を感じているでしょう
でも何の特色もない 空気のような
真空のように 自分がなんとなく自分という
微かな なんとなく自分という意識さえであって何もない
ですから そういう状態を体験したら
やっぱり真我はニルグナであると
特色なしと ふうなことを哲学的に言われるし
こういう言葉があることは
もしかするとこういう無色界の経験もあった人々がいたということ
仏教経典から見れば当たり前にいたんです
たくさん お釈迦様は非想非想非想処まで教えていただいたんだ
方法は 大体ここまで行ってヴィパッサナー瞑想はちょっと無理なんです
ここまで行っちゃうと
ヴィパッサナー サマーディして瞑想する人々は無色界には行かないんです
無色界は置いといて 色界で第四禅定のところでヴィパッサナーに入るんです
第四禅定終わって無色界も終わって
それからヴィパッサナーやろうと思っちゃうと
結構難しいんですね 観察するものがないんだから
いわゆる無常はドーンと体験しなきゃね
生滅転換の波のように
ですから 大体このサマーディやってヴィパッサナーする人々は第四禅定の方で終わるんです
やめてサマーディ ヴィパッサナーに入る
あるいは八番目まで行っても
普通に戻ってから 普通の愉快な心に戻ってから
ヴィパッサナーまた別に始まるんです
別に始まっちゃうとヴィパッサナーの智慧が成長すると同時にサマーディの方もついてきて第四禅定にくるんです
第四禅定になってから
ヴィパッサナーの悟りの境地に入るんです
で 仏教の 例えば悟り開いたならば
完全に阿羅漢になったならば
もう最低 不還果にでもなったならば
その人には煩悩はない
存在したいという気持ちもない
もうそこでその方々は瞑想して
例えば非想非想非想処に行ったと
やはり心は何か何も認識しないかするか言わない微かな状態になったと
その時になったところで
存在したいという煩悩もないんだから
これもやめてもらったらどうですかと
この波も その人にだけそれできるんです
やめられるんです そこでこの波が
ここで切っちゃう 流れが
心の波が それも一つの禅定なんです
もう完全に消える 心の波が
それはみんなにできない
阿羅漢になっているか預流果になっているか
預流果じゃなくて不還果になっているか
どっちかです それでサマーディもなければダメなんです
そうすると心ももう物質はすでにもう機能しなくなっているし
心の機能もここで切れちゃう
それは何？滅尽定と読むんですね
ニローダ・サマーパッティというんです
ニローダ 滅つと 日本語で滅尽と読むんですね
尽というのは煩悩が消えたという意味で
パーリ語だったらニローダっていうのはもう滅つと定なんですね
滅尽定なんですね そこで生きていながらも涅槃という状態が体験できるんです
消えるという状態 その時はもうはっきりと書いているんです
体は動かないんだと 体の機能は心も止まったんだからね
体の物質も何も機能しないんです
普通の物質と変わっちゃうんです
で すごく違う禅定で だからこの禅定のリストに仏教から付け加えているのはそれだけなんです
他のものはもう既成 既成リスト
それはリスト お釈迦 仏教で使っているリストですけどね
他の宗教で瞑想はあるんだけど
禅定もあるんだけど こういう風な順番のリストはないんです
ないし そのリストに これは仏教が勝手に作っているリストですけど
そこに仏教からはこの滅尽定を付け加えているんです
で このヴィパッサナーの悟りっていうのは
そのサマーディはたった瞬間だけ体験できるんです
預流果になると 一来果になるということは
たった瞬間だけそのサマーディを体験できるんです
ずっと体験したければサマーディやらなくちゃいけない
悟ったというのは その滅尽定をほんの瞬間だけ体験する
それで煩悩が消えちゃう
煩悩を消す気持ちがないと体験できません
ヴィパッサナーは何年やっても煩悩でやっちゃうと生まれない
ないんです 本気になって煩悩を消したくなった瞬間で
心が整っているならば
集中力も結構続いているならば
生まれるんです いいと言えばちょっとした心の働きなんですね
それを体験しちゃったら
この心の波の力っていうのはもう全部崩れちゃうんですね
もう輪廻転生しない で
仏教でなんで永遠のという言葉を使わないで
もう涅槃という概念に入れてるんだ
それも永遠ではないかと理屈は言えるのかもしれません
だけど仏教はそこの場合も合理的なんですね
こういう働きがあるんだから
煩悩という働きがあるんだから輪廻転生すると
そこで煩悩という働きは消してしまうんだと
消したら輪廻転生しないんだと
それで話は終わりと 永遠という言葉を使わない
話も終わり 言葉も終わり
全て終わりと 語るな それ以上もう
だからその涅槃についても
仏教はこの合理的なステータスは守っているんです
涅槃に入った人は永遠ですと言っちゃったら
お釈迦様にものすごく怒られるんです
これは邪道だと じゃあ永遠じゃないか
どういう邪道な考え方なんだ
言葉はそれ以上 そこで終わりと
輪廻転生しない そういうことで
これはこれで話は終わりますけど
時間もなくなりましたし
一応その 4つの禅定 無色界の 4つの禅定
で それは一般の人々は禅定に入ると
この先心というんですね
クサラチット それから禅定に入ってから亡くなって梵天に生まれ変わったとする
その場合はヴィパーカチット
依熟心というんですね
同じ心なんですね だから 4つありまして
先心は 4つと依熟心が 4つと
阿羅漢になった聖者たちがその禅定に入っちゃうと遺作心というんです
それで無色界の心が 12種類出てくるんです
4 かける 3 で で 無色界はそれで終了します
で もう 4時半まで 5時まで
え？じゃあ 15分オーバーにしてるんです
そういうことをみんな軽々く
この仏教とどんな宗教も同じ同じと言うんだけど
そんな軽々く言えるかどうかね
言うならば きちんと他の宗教のこともちゃんと勉強して
例えばヨーガでもきちんと徹底的に勉強してきた方がいいんです
シャンカラの本であろうが
ヨーガ・スートラですか
そういうものでも徹底的にやってから
仏教が似ているかと 僕にとればね
この間そういう話がものすごくあったんだから
ね それはヒンドゥー教で仙人たちも同じことを言ってるんだと
何が仏教だけですかと言うと
人に怒られたんだけどね
私は返事するんではなくて
何を決めたんですかと
これからはこの人には親切に教え事はしないんだと
カットと それを軽々く決めるんだったら
もうどうしようもないんです
[背景音]